[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by roman griffin
davis aka art in silent night which is
in select theaters and on amc plus
december 3rd how you doing today roman
i'm good uh i just i got to come back
home early from school and that was
great because i had um oh
next
that's all
yeah it's awesome you get to do this now
yeah
yeah that's great man um so it's
exciting too because with this film that
your mom actually wrote and directed
did you get to put any say into the
actual script that she wrote when she
was writing it
no
no no no i mean i got it i literally i
maybe i've i've heard so much of it
because we'd be at dinner and then um
you know she probably she'd basically
read like the whole script while with
her and then we didn't really have much
saying whether she
and she was yeah so we basically had to
i probably maybe listened to it maybe
seven times
nah i i'm a sad your man
no i love that i got to the point where
i i just
i had i heard it so many times that i
wasn't very fussed anymore whether i'd
like to follow no because i was just
at the point where i heard it too many
times
no that that makes complete sense and
also her being the director was that
surreal on set being with your brothers
and then yeah having your mom direct she
was great i mean she's told me and my
brothers what to do ever since we were
born really and it was fine
so um yeah it was like it was it was
weird it was like i kind of i kind of
thinking this should be slightly weird
you know it's
i'm working with my brothers and mom
yeah and we acquire a big responsibility
because quite a lot of money has gone
into the project worth working on so um
yeah
yeah i mean
she was able to be you know
very honest and um
it was great um she really
helped me um
perform
in a better manner
yeah i mean so did that feel like it was
like just also more comfortable on set
having that experience having your mom
kind of leaving the charge
yeah yeah it felt um
because i mean i mean i've been uh to my
dad sets a lot and i've always felt like
um
you know that annoying kid that always
visited like always visits
like a workplace
yeah
it was weeks i felt like that as well
and it was oh yeah
so
yeah
yeah so speaking of your dad who is a
famous cinematographer
having you have these two super talented
parents does that
also make you want to write or direct or
do cinematography maybe one day
um
well they uh
if
i mean i've gone to the point
oh can i have a second that way i i have
an answer but um i don't want to butcher
it you know so i'm just gonna pop it in
my head
let it come to you
um
i mean i i would in a way but um it felt
you know it always it feels a bit weird
when you uh do
when you you do the same work as your
parents in a way
you feel like you have
uh
especially when they think they're good
at it then you still haven't
no they are very good
but i'm not saying that like they
they're not good but they think they are
but they generally are good but um
it gets to the point where you're just
having to um
it's like you're competing in a way and
that just feels event
it's a church that um
that i could be it caused quite an
awkward
like reunion
yeah
yeah so
yeah no for sure um
and just speaking of all these like big
actors you've already worked with and
actresses is there any current ones you
look up to right now
um
i look up to a lot of actors
um
i mean they're all really amazing
um
my favorite actor is carrie grant
uh
most amazing actor yeah that's that's a
great answer um and then just speaking
with actors in this film and style night
you worked with is there anything you
kind of learned from working with like
akira knightley or matthew good on set
is there any are you kind of always
observing their techniques
um
yeah i already do that with all the axes
fan clowns
um yeah
yeah i'll be fine there was loads of
cakes in the greenhouse so i'm in the
green room so
you know it was always
so i kind of liked
i was um
i enjoyed staying there more than on set
to frankly oh hell yeah yeah it's good
cake and stuff
yeah i mean
they had um
it was always different every day as
well
yeah that's that's awesome um
so having that you're in jojo rabbit
which is other
blends of comedy like this film
do you have a preference of what type of
films you like to do or is comedy kind
of like your main thing you really like
um
well
i do like i do like comedies but um
uh
well
when i
when i was able to do both of these
films i couldn't they were so good i
couldn't really say no
so it wasn't like whether it was a genre
that like it was more like
they're so good that i can't not do them
so
but i i would have a preference tonight
i mean
i don't really think about you know
yeah hell yeah and and speaking of that
first film your first film being this
huge success in jojo rabbit do you
already feel kind of pressure in your
young career to live up to that is that
already kind of
something you think about
um
well i don't want to get worse from that
i guess
well i don't wanna i don't really wanna
in terms of um
how well i do on a film i don't really
wanna peek at my youngest because i'm
it's a bit depressing
um
yeah
that's a good attitude to have yeah just
keep going up man you're gonna and is is
there any hobbies besides acting you
love to do like sports gaming anything
like that
i do do a lot of gaming
oh yeah
yeah yeah
i i i play a lot of valor
oh cool um and then
what is the ultimate dream for roman
griffin davis like do you want that
oscar one day is that like what's your
aspiring to do
uh
i've never already
i've never really thought about um
uh awards and whatnot i more thought
about you know just being able to work
really
yeah
i guess i guess that's everyone's dream
sure yeah sure pretty bad speech of the
oscars
so with this film silent night for
people who are huge fans of you already
from jojo rabbit
what what is it they can look forward to
about this film with you and in
particular like why should they check
this film out
um
well i think it talks about a a lot of
um
interesting
things and it's i guess
it it's quite important to
it
is it's got it talks about important
discussions that i guess the world
really needs to listen to
because um it's quite surreal
the film
yeah
quite a
ambiguous one i'm big it's quite like a
an extreme
an extreme scenario
yeah it's totally and you you really do
an awesome job in this film and it's so
awesome to watch your performance in it
um everybody should be really excited to
watch roman crush it in silent night
it's in select theaters and on amc plus
december 3rd
roman thank you so much for joining me
today man i hope to talk to you in the
future one day
you too